hello and welcome to this video
playing barney
tough to say how this is pronounced from
the philippines
okay all right so i got
three videos on today and tomorrow
there will be probably something
different
as there's a quarantine leak
plate it's actually tomorrow
no so i will probably do a quarantine
league
video which will be roughly 90 minutes
of the whole tournament
but um i confused
the the days so that probably will be on
on friday
anyway so here we have a moroxy bind
a little bit confused why black is
taking so much time
early on
yeah bishop d7 or knight txd4 is what
they normally do
it's increment so this um you can take a
bit of time if you know
that you can speed up and
don't lose all that much in terms of
quality
still a bit odd a6
queen d2 is kind of normal
i also play knight c2 regularly in these
lines but
it's not a huge
difference in quality you can
play it like i'm doing now as well i
just have to be a little bit
cautious with precise move order
i think here f4 is a thing
f4 queen a5
yeah should be fine queen a5
threatens knight takes e4
this is a standard tactic
this f4 approach it becomes interesting
if black plays with bishop e6
like he did here now he is switching
back to bishop d7
uh set up okay
i can play
c6 well sometimes you can go
e5 and directly punish black for
possibly punish black form the move
order
okay bishop to d3
this is a bit bit different this f4
approach than
your typical f3 type of meroxie bind
here
white is playing a bit more aggressively
the d4 bishop is not defended this is
something that
might prompt tactics yeah like this one
i was just thinking about it yeah
that this is uh maybe possible
um if i take twice then he has knight
takes a form
so i probably
probably should have played this a bit
differently
okay i can take an e5
but then he can also move the knight due
to my unprotected bishop he doesn't have
to recapture so
i rather go back and now have the idea
to play f5
um you know knight g4 is
definitely an idea as well for black
knight g4 will more or less secure that
he's getting the bishop i mean i have no
square to go to
this will be hectic at the end yeah he's
taking a lot of time and
the same is basically true for me
okay so i'm pushing the knight
back
okay
it's not so much that i'd love that
bishop but i want to have the
d file half open
okay it's an interesting question if i
should
trade this bishop with bishop h6 or not
i will do that
i'm not sure about it
but i think that potentially weakening
his king
can be a good thing
it's not clear bishop e3
bishop e3 to d4 also made quite a bit of
sense
why he's taking ages
it's really odd
yeah so that's a double attack but i
didn't really think that
i have to worry about bishop takes e4
here
he might still want to do it
i have rook f4 though okay so he's
preparing queen g7 i think
[Music]
yeah he's doing okay
the move f5 is possible i think it's
just good i mean
i think he does not dare to play it with
the
with the time ticking down
okay
94 is desirable but it doesn't have many
squares
so this is an interesting ending where
black is fine
but let's see what happens
a3 prepare b4
i still have a lot more space
i'm not sure if that was a good idea you
can play rook 8 now
yeah that was probably not so great
oh yes 95 check here but okay
don't see really what else
wow that's a strange square
um
if possible i'd like to
have this bishop on f3 so that the
knight is more or less dominated
it looks like the right way to do it and
my pawns should
win the game
yeah and that's it
it was a bit um it was not really a
game where i had control over things
i think he had many good opportunities
and it seems like i did something wrong
around here
after like allowing allowing this tactic
was not with e5 i mean was not really
really good
so it turns out that e5 is strong i mean
i kind of suspected that but i couldn't
i i saw this obviously
but now e5 is attacked and i couldn't
quite
figure this out queen f4 is is stronger
ever
i saw that but i wasn't sure about it
i bet it is strong right i mean what's
what's his move here
h5
i can just put this here
then h3 it's good for idea okay
so b3 is lame
and in particularly lame now here with
bishop d3 e5 which is strong
and here here i'm fighting for
fighting for equality basically takes
takes
this one i i actually think that
okay here's bishop d4
so i should start with king h1
but i mean the general structure i think
should be roughly equal
i don't think um that
black's better here or
on the opposite end of the spectrum that
i'm better bishop h6
i played yeah the engine wants to play
bishop e3 indeed yeah
i mean that looked better right here
okay this is indeed i think he can take
the pawn actually
um i mean maybe not now but
like here f5 that's what i meant the f5
that that's what i meant with taking the
pawn yeah so
this this was possible here or we played
this
and again f5 i think that works
i think he was maybe irritated with the
time being
down and he's playing more or less like
non-committal moves but um yeah here
i'm i'm quite happy again with the
position
and i could have taken a5 i didn't see
that at all
i mean now now it's more or less um
more or less a bullet game with an
increment queen g3
king here
yeah this this ending this is an
interesting ending because when black
has
the um has the knight on a good spot
and has a mobile pawn majority on the
kings side so that must be
good for black in some way but it turned
around pretty quickly
nah not pretty quickly that's wrong but
i think i was
um at least out of trouble
quite quickly so king g7 is what the
engine prefers simply keeping
the e file situation and then f5 i guess
that is not a mistake i i don't think
for
for black
before i mean i played b4 quite quickly
and i'm not sure about it so it takes
takes rook a8 is kind of
looks kind of obvious and um
i wasn't sure here at all rookie one
okay this is good for wyatt
that's interesting
yeah rookie six is a thing yeah one one
thing probably
here if they play knight e5 trying to
block that
i can take on e5 yes that is not
particularly surprising and this is uh
just
a deadly steamroller
yeah that that's clear so he has to play
rookie 8 it seems
then this is preferable for sure my move
i mean
again it was very very low a very low
time
um i i just wanted to make sure that
he's not invading on the third rank
knight e5 i thought c5 actually there
seems to be an issue with the move
oh yeah okay the issue is b takes b
takes and check
that probably would have won then for
him because i think i would have played
c5 here
and this is not a good position
okay a1 and now i was very hectic at g4
probably not great
and here i believe that that should be
fine really with the super active king
unless he has
some something great
and now there's a very small
rook f1 okay once you see it it kind of
makes sense yeah that's basically
chasing the bishop the whole time i have
to move it and tick and chase me the
whole time i have no good square to go
to
oh i i clearly cannot um let's say go
here as then the f
pawn is running and this is probably
lost now
as i win win all those pawns
yeah that is lost and don't think
my technical play can probably be
improved but
it's not i don't think i i could have
taken the knight okay
i mean if you have eight seconds
i can take the night the whole time
that's crazy but i was just simply
looking at the pawns and seeing that i
can promote them
so still you should see that
anyway yeah so i didn't play the opening
phase right yeah
right after like here
here the movie five is really really
what i should play here
okay yeah thanks for watching